let's talk about math a little bit if
you think about the earliest math skills
I'm already having a hard time even
taking it seriously now with the picture
that has popped up behind me of
Kellyanne Conway if you think about the
earliest math skills that most kids
learn it starts with counting right you
learn one you learn too you learn three
eventually you get to being able to
compare single-digit numbers three is
more than one four is less than eight
that's sort of math skill number two and
then you might go to two-digit numbers
right like Oh twenty-three twenty-four
twenty-five you're a big boy now you
know two-digit numbers and then very
soon thereafter you know maybe by age
five six I don't remember exactly you
would be able to say okay 87 is more
than 54 or forty-three is less than 65
that's like I don't know kindergarten
first grade campaign co-manager for
Donald Trump Kellyanne Conway showed up
on CNN's Anderson Cooper and she seemed
to not understand that 47 is a bigger
number than any number that is in the
30s that seemed to not enter into her
skull and I'm gonna play it for you and
yes it is embarrassing I would get the
kids out of the room for this and let's
explore it together and see what
happened here
do you believe that that is enough to
win do you believe you can depress
Democratic turnout by going after
Hillary Clinton by going after Bill
Clinton why think Hillary Clinton's
being been depressing Democratic turnout
my goodness why is this woman at 46%
she's like the magic 46 she's 46 percent
in the new NBC news/wall Street Journal
poll she's 46 percent of lotteries and
try part of it
well what Anderson she's running as the
first female president who's got has a
sitting president and first lady much
more popular than she cares below she's
got it is it a question well used you're
saying for you you asked me if I thought
right yes no I one needs not be a
pollster to know that but here's the
deal I'm asking you why someone who has
all these advantages you're asking me
how we win and if Hillary Clinton can't
enthuse her base in her turn out enough
can she win she still doesn't have this
voter you'd think counting two-digit
numbers wouldn't perplex the manager of
a national presidential campaign I'll
credit Kellyanne for being very quick
and being able to redirect in a way that
many people don't realize is a weasel
technique and that use of is there a
question that is a textbook technique
that is used and the the it's
interesting because the reason Anderson
Cooper interjected with that is because
her answer to his question made
absolutely no sense
how is 46% objectively bad for Hillary
Clinton if in the same poll donald trump
her candidate has 37% and this is a
technique that your trot taught in media
training which is if you start being
peppered with facts that are counter to
your narrative you respond with is there
a question there and it can sometimes be
effective where the audience will say
you know what that's true they were
bullying her there was no question there
this also might set the record most of
the records set by Trump and his
surrogates are not good records this
might also set the record for inaccurate
statements in 60 seconds really though
I'm feeling pretty ready for Election
Day we're already well into planning
content for after the election I don't
know about you guys Pat and Rachel but
I'm ready to be done with this sort of
knuckleheaded nonsense from everybody
from Scottie Nell Hughes and Kellyanne
Conway and Jeffrey Lord that Trump
supporter that goes on CNN are you
feeling fatigued by all this yet Rachel
yeah I mean I'm feeling pretty fatigues
but I have to say I'm not kind of
surprised because she seems to kind of
also go along with the the Trump
narrative of not really preparing for
anything dancing around questions
especially when Anderson was asking her
about the the recent ad attacking
Hillary's meant are not meant yeah
mental health I believe it was yeah I
mean it's not directly indirectly for
sure right showing her coughing and
stumbling and asking kind of the
motivation and why they were doing this
one he's already alienated the female
vote and she just kept kind of dancing
around it yeah well kind of toward her
credits who she has a very difficult job
here I mean yeah campaign is filing a
pilot spiraling out of control and you
know it just he's probably not gonna win
this election and yeah I mean these
these
Media cycles are about a year and a half
now so by this time I'm definitely
fatigued I'm ready for November 9th and
I think a lot in our audience also all
right
what is she the CEO of again I think
it's just like a campaign strategy you
know some kind of political strategy
group right I mean she's basically a
strategist usually there it's just like
she's the CEO of her own consulting firm
I guess right but if it's the focused on
strategy I guess that doesn't really
make a lot of sense to me because I feel
like when she's kind of brought into not
necessarily clean up trumps messes but
kind of explain them couched them in a
way you can always kind of couch things
positively or in a better angle I I feel
like she it just falls flat yeah her
lies need to be much better crafted to
be even slightly more believable Gamefly
is sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDPS
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free
30-day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s